here it's washed it for lice fillet
elbows by pulling fly before the
Washington coz silly how's it going bros
my name is pierre 2-pack welcome to the
last of us left behind dlc if you
haven't played the first game or watched
it on youtube or whatever god you you
have to it was one of the best games of
2013 without a doubt it feels great to
be back you know it feels great to
revisit revisit the universe of the last
of us it's always really sad when a game
is over so when DLC like this comes out
it's it's always something very very
exciting and you bros have been going
crazy for weeks for me to actually play
the game and it's like of course I'm
gonna play it but yeah without further
ado um let's begin I'm so excited I hope
I remember how to play it's been a while
um I'm sure we'll be okay we're [ __ ]
fireflies get down oh the [ __ ] are these
guys going on here
what's your over on me Hey
come on we're gonna play from here
anything think we're safe
oh [ __ ]
Joe yeah
ah you don't tell me what to do you plug
it up they load the wrong safe or
something
No
huh all right well this is interesting
okay
oh damn
Riley Apple I landed on my hip
what the hell I thought I was bidden I
know it was gradual awesome that's her
face come here
I haven't seen you and I don't even know
how long 45 days
well 46 technically I want to know what
I've been up to oh this time I thought
you were dead
yeah here
well
no way what is that still no roommate I
had to sleep under Liz for three years
and you know how bad that girl's mouth
are so she she's part of the fireflies
and a Firefly
and that's a picture we've seen before
you still have it up what what are you
doing I'm making sure I don't get caught
with a Firefly relax there are no
soldiers on the entire floor here
Congrats hey are we cool are we cool I
disappeared and you're mad and I owe you
an explanation let's get out of here and
I'll tell you all about it it's almost
morning and I have military drills you
know where we learn how to kill
fireflies put some pants on and let's go
god damn it got away pants now so dumb
come on when have we ever gotten into
trouble here we go yeah we're out well
put you on your side
Oh
I think they'll do it I guess again
should buy us some time
find something to stitch you up okay
Kalas keep an eye on Calais is hanging
out by the yogurt I'll be back in a
flash
promise so there you go alright exciting
that's all I got this all right now are
the [ __ ] do I go it's so weird to be
back man
all right well I guess we this color to
my own place excellent excellent
I I forgot how amazing the cutscenes are
in this game like it's it's incredible
what they pulled off with a ps3 honestly
like they look so good I want games like
this crochet to come out on that ps4
already it's like not a single game out
on the ps4 all right
are there any No
we're fine okay here Weston's pharmacy
that sounds promising uh how do what
stuff up this is American yes how do I
can I go in here that's a long okay
that's kind of creepy I don't want to go
away only I can miss a window one feet
away yeah goddamnit
alright I guess we're gonna sneak in
here oh I like this okay one of a guy
maybe something here huh what the hell
huh did you just throw all the pills and
leave the bottle God God
goddamn crackheads these days what do we
got here anything looks like a pile of
[ __ ] I can't believe you touch that
ah of course oh [ __ ] picked clean that
guy scared me what the hell is that the
hell are you doing uh okay I got it
first thing uh-huh
how the [ __ ] do I get inside hey watch
your [ __ ] language i enraged no potty
mouth what is this please read
pharmacist maybe he's got a key
pharmacist went crazy and attacked me I
hit him pretty hard he's unconscious I
locked him in the American princess
store next door please get him help
combination 35 30 31 all right
that's simple enough off we go twenty
percent off oh nothing great it's like a
real sailing here okay
thing milord is yeah it's here 35 right
3 left 31 right that worked but Ella
remember because I didn't oh oh he's
gonna be bad girl [ __ ] yeah if you're
gonna jump out of me Quinn [ __ ] knew
it
Oh
this place is creepy man what Dad is
going on
I hate dolls Hey Oh
ah one guy does oh uh [ __ ] man it's
gusting [ __ ] spores man this is worse
when I place boy huh guys nothing happy
too obvious yeah uh you guys scared key
pharmacy let's do it oh it's only sad to
see like heaven people becoming
mushrooms and [ __ ] is so [ __ ] death
they mad [ __ ]
what Oh are we gonna stab that [ __ ]
don't want to [ __ ] this up it's been a
while I don't know if I remember how to
do this got stabbed a [ __ ] in the
throat that's right that's how we do it
in the pot a pot pound girl gotta grab
one of these ah I remember how crazy
Ellie is with the freaking knife man
yeah what are you having doing here nice
hair though
gotta say it's pretty her here we go yes
it's better have something no guess I
would have been too easy huh hmm Oh a
military helicopter huh that's gotta
have something how the hell did I get EJ
so I'd miss very it's kind of cool it
would be kind of cool to live in this
world I'm getting not like Mozambique
was the same we kind of cool just walk
around and loot [ __ ] and stab people and
throw flame or you can just got a like
Mexico or something I'm just kidding
sorry Mexicans pixie tackle down I go in
here
this doesn't look any more safe okay
it's fine
chef here
rarity nail huh Oh God
don't come to life man oh yeah that's is
it Oh thought it was a Nazi with the
thing on his arm
ah no sutures well at least I can use
this
what's a suture never heard of that
you're sure don't know Reuters yeah I'm
sorry okay all right if you want to read
that you can cause so much text and I'm
sitting too far away from the screen all
right
it was still need to get to the
helicopter
here we go what hurry up here oh I was
close huh you got a fast there I'm
impressed
well yeah well come on up we go so how
did you find them the fireflies yeah
remember that Firefly you bitten stole
his gun yeah I remember him that's
Trevor I saw him walking down the street
so I tailed his ass I follow him into
this alley and all these fireflies
ambushed me they took me right to their
hideout to Marlene were you scared
terrified I thought this time she would
actually shoot me but I said she just
says what took you so long she was
expecting me and she just made you a
Firefly
something like that that hole almost
killing me thing was a test
hmm she wanted to know I was committed
oh come on we're making good time
who do you hang out with these days I
don't know someone really loser
what about Tino and the rest of the guys
how are they doing Riley those are your
friends but you talked to them yeah I
get us
this is
look further why you found the light yet
Oh
har-har oh I'm sorry I didn't mean to
offend your people so what'd you buy
into this whole thing now all I know is
that I'm not a soldier
thirty days my ass people are getting
infected all the time they just do a
good job of hiding it huh you've run
into more infected huh that's part of my
initiation they actually made me killed
it yeah oh oh [ __ ] hi where
yeah I'm sure they'll see him oh man
sorry I'm a bit jumpy lately
careful it's wet
hey so maybe I should join the fireflies
le that was the first thing I asked my
mom she wants you safe at that stupid
school I'm not even supposed to come see
you why does she care
she's worried I'll get you into trouble
hey remember the first time I brought
you here what are we doing here Riley I
have a surprise for you
what is it a dinosaur I'll be your
friend again if it's a dinosaur
you'll just have to wait and see it's
funny how like they're total badasses
but they still care about dinosaurs and
[ __ ] you forget that they grew up in a
world where you know I got them back our
water guns [ __ ] you telling me
corporal [ __ ] gave them back to you
of course not I had to sneak into his
office Riley I have them in my hands but
your ass got caught uh-huh my ass got
caught
that's what I was saying you forget that
they grew up in a world that isn't
normal like all the traditions and stuff
that we would do
I can't believe Winston's gone you heard
yeah do you know how it happened I guess
I have to ask you huh I don't know let's
see what he left us really what the hell
is this
what what is this Winston ran guy used
to be handsome bingo
awesome what is that alcohol Oh
III don't think Elly's character would
say yes to to it I'm good
more for me cheers Winston whoa they
whiskey strong come on there you go
where did it go
oh I'd say how did I doesn't seem safe
to drink outside of safe areas I'm just
looking out for okay Oh judge places
what happened to princess I assumed
after Winston died they took her oh poor
horse she's probably out there terrified
man poor princess man where are we going
anyway
everyone to the same mall I win the same
place no yeah no Ellie
help me lift this okay yeah always feels
like we're gonna get crushed it's fine
I'll go first then go ahead you know
what uh how about we find another way
yeah
huh sounds good if I used to the love
you bear your bear
oh I'm have to find it okay what what
was that hey Riley
you know what I'll get you up and over
see if you're gonna unlock it from the
inside
good call what's happening well you see
anything
Riley god damn it what oh the hell yeah
you dig there's two times today the
hell's wrong with you how the hell did
we never find this place
come on I got the perfect mass for you
okay that's awesome really perfect this
is Oh what is that like a Wolfman or
something a [ __ ] man even better so
stupid
thank you yeah bad have no more aah
rawr Alan really [ __ ] roar hey okay
I'm touching me ah there she is
now let's see what else this place has
roar [ __ ] what else - the guy in
here good what look at all yeah that's
pretty badass
oh hell yeah
ah triple Phoenix swaggy Birds mask so
much better so much better look at day
adorable why thank you kind pigeon
hey I know piggy [ __ ] how about swaggy
sweet squeeze where I'd swag your sub so
I don't know what bird boy that's okay
can't damn it that's awesome
that's awesome we're looking for
something here we're supposed to do
something like what my doing he heard
you did it dad
here we go ah I got an idea
why see those cars down there Yeah right
one's yours I'll be blue we throw bricks
whoever breaks all the windows to their
car win are you kidding me I'm like the
brick master all right
loser has to answer a question no
sarcasm Oh what is this truth or truth
all right fool you're on every damn is
O'Shea aha
you suck look at this Shay yeah how you
do it I freaking love Bailey's dagger
whoa
BuChE BuChE [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you gotta
win gotta pay the troll toll you gotta
pay ya like that
Boosh mother [ __ ] yeah don't sway ha ha
right if I win this I'm I win this beer
crash okay
okay bear all right
one more baby that's one one to go yes
Rick mast [ __ ] master my car had
tougher windows yeah whatever
loser alright question time I'm scared
Rick it love le man why did you leave
that why did you lash out didn't Marleen
miss my mom my um dearly heard anything
about her mom why did you why do you um
okay why did you leave without telling
me I was in a weird space look I didn't
tell anyone but I wasn't just anyone was
I know it's just you gotta see this
thing and we're almost there come on why
are you dancing though hmm you didn't
answer my question
yeah why are you dancing answer answer
me why are you dancing why are you
dancing come on Tammy why are you
dancing
why did it wait wait wait hey who are
you dancing from cat
what are we doing here
place is creeping me out yeah so you
know we thought they only powered
certain areas of the city yeah
follow me warning major banks these
people are in desperate and you can
pause and read it I'm sorry I'm sorry
but let's continue I know there are some
people but I think in the majority don't
want to read all the notes so turns out
the whole city has power they just flip
the circuit breakers all you got to do
is flip it back am I am I gonna am I
gonna flip me there's no way this is
gonna work what did I tell you wait so
the whole mall is lit up let's go find
out
well I guess I don't what what are you
good Ally you're freaking me out stop
okay how did [ __ ] know do you see this
wait I I know what you're trying to do
and I'm really glad that you're not dead
I mean
I'm glad that we're back together and I
didn't mean it all that stuff I said
before I left I didn't mean any of it
Riley you're such a SAP
I just started it oh man
are you ready totally are you kidding
what what what what looks like we're
gonna have to end the first episode here
it looks very interesting and promising
so far leave like if you enjoy watching
and say want to help supporting this
series I it feels really good to back in
with these type of videos I I know
there's been a lot of like random
one-off videos lately but I think with
series it's really nice to have a
display a game together that's that's
how I see it and I I hope you like it
that way
[ __ ] I'll slap your ass anyway um
that's it for me I'll see you tomorrow
with the new episode thank you for
watching stay awesome